hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my forum readers who's
asking about backlinking so wrote in
asking in your opinion what's your back
linking packages contain what do you
think are the most effective strategies
that can be used in back looking so you
coming a little old school but I don't
believe in buying links I haven't bought
backlinks is part of my website and I
think it can have a negative impact on
the long-term success of your business
right if you're caught by backlinks it
can have a big negative impact on your
rankings in the search engines so you
want to think long term and where your
business is going to go you want to
avoid vine backlinks but there are a
couple of great ways that you can build
backlinks legitimately that can help you
with your rankings and I want to share a
couple of those with you today so the
first that I really enjoy is using a
press and hopefully you're an expert in
whatever you're doing as an entrepreneur
we should be experts in our field and
whenever the media is covering of story
they're looking for experts to come and
comment on it so you should be that
expert why not you right you should be
really good at what you're what you're
doing so the first step is to build up a
media list think of anybody who covers
your industry and start creating
potential stories for them and try not
to create a press release but actually
give them a story idea that can be
really useful and helpful and when I
first started doing this every week I
would send out a new story idea to my
list and almost always got picked up by
at least one media outlet and again
whenever I'm credited they link to my
website hopefully so it's a great way to
build backlinks and the media sites are
usually very high authority and can have
a nice impact on your google rankings so
that's one great way to do it the other
way that I used more often now is I
subscribe to service called PR leads and
this is where reporters will publish
their stories that they're looking for
experts on so they haven't actually
created their story yet there's the
lists all the topics that they're going
to be right in development that they
need expert commentary for so you could
be that expert
talked about before and as a demo I'm on
my website on how to use it it's 100
bucks a month or ninety nine dollars a
month but it's super useful and I found
it's gotten me into the New York Times a
couple other big-name media outlets so
definitely great way to check out and
you're going to be spending money
instead of buying backlinks this could
be a good investment of that money the
second thing I found really useful in
terms of building up backlinks is
testimonials so think about all the
different products and services that you
use and offer the company at testimonial
assume when you really like the service
and you want to you know put your name
on it entrepreneur is always looking for
people to leave testimonials and if you
contact the company and say hey I really
like using your product or service I'd
love to offer a testimonial for you if
they link to your website and usually
when people are showing in testimonials
they've put in a pretty prominent place
right you don't want to bury your
testimonials you want to showcase it
front and center your happy customers so
this could be an opportunity for you to
potentially you can get on the homepage
which can carry a lot more linking power
than being buried somewhere on an inside
page so right to the companies that you
you know you use their product tell them
you like to create a testimonial and you
can include even a picture or
potentially even a video as long as they
link back to your website as part of the
credit and you should people are more
than happy to do that it's a great way
to build up a one way link from
established websites the last thing that
I find really helpful is building great
content and you want to build content
that people want to link to so part of
that is just having really really good
content that people enjoy but you can
also design some content that is made to
be shared and made to be linked to so
anytime you're talking about social
media or blogs Facebook Twitter that
kind of stuff you're probably going to
get a lot of links into your site so one
of the things that we do is every month
we'll create a top 50 list of blogs for
a different area that still deals with
entrepreneurship so one month it could
be top 50 social media blogs next month
it could be top 50 Human Resources blogs
still tied to entrepreneurship and then
we'll let the bloggers who are on the
list know about it and we'll tweet about
it and let all of our fans know about it
and what that generates is a lot of
linking in
get upwards of thousand links coming
just to that one post because people
want to share those types of things so
anytime you have a top list people love
that kind of stuff and what that does is
not only help boost that one page but it
helps your entire link profile for your
website and everything else starts to
benefit from those links so you built in
as well so having those kind of key
pieces of content that can build links
is super helpful as well so hopefully
that gives you some ideas of what I've
done that's been successful you know by
links can be an effective short term
strategy I don't have any success or
examples to share with you from my own
experience but hopefully what I gave is
useful and helpful if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up and I'd
love to hear your thoughts and feedback
especially if you've done your own link
building strategies leave a comment
below the video and stay tuned for the
next episode
you
you